[Music]
all eyes on the final presidential
debate tomorrow
the stakes incredibly high for both
candidates joe biden bracing for attacks
from president trump
over his son hunter the biden campaign
preemptively responding with a statement
that reads in part and here i'm quoting
when donald trump obsesses over
right-wing fringe conspiracy theories
he merely reinforces what we've said the
whole time
that he's forced to run away from his
own record because his pandemic response
continues
to be a train wreck and even some in the
gop
are urging trump to focus on policy over
personal attacks
the los angeles times notes that all the
chaos in the final stretch could be
exhausting
the very voters that trump needs dana
do you think that if the president
chooses to focus on hunter
it could move votes well i think that
the people
it's hard to say right um one one third
of the vote is already in
by tomorrow night because of early
voting okay so there's that
you already have people who are said
that they're committed they we know that
president trump
trump president trump's actually talking
about the debate now let's listen
about who
well i think the mute is very unfair and
i think it's very bad that they're not
talking about foreign affairs they're
supposed to be talking about foreign
affairs
and i think that the anchor is a very
uh biased person her parents are very
biased
but that's my life in the meantime
that's the white house standing behind
me right mr trump
yeah i do prep i do prep
the attorney general that's joe biden
and his son
thank you very much everybody mr
president have you abandoned the fight
against
all right well that was president trump
uh about to get in the helicopter i
think he's going out in north carolina
for some campaign
a campaign rally this evening but dana
you were saying well i just
you know he is um one he's i think he's
doing something very smart he's
suggesting that he's the underdog in the
debate tomorrow night
um he's also suggesting you know he's
roughing up the
the ref the moderator um i don't think
that's entirely fair because we'll have
let's see how she does
um and just because your parents may
have given contributions so democrats
doesn't mean that you have
but the other thing is that i think that
he is going to do is he
one he'll be sharper and if you anyone
who's seen hamilton
there's a song where aaron burr gives
hamilton some really great advice that's
good for everybody
which is to talk less and smile more
he's already indicated that he's going
to talk less to let biden
go ahead and take the lead and if you
remember in the nbc town hall last week
there was that one lady the voter she
said that president trump had a very
nice smile
indeed so brett uh if in fact
the president brings up hunter biden
there are democrats who are saying well
you know what why doesn't the vice
president bring up ivanka bring up the
fact that
jared's not qualified to run the covet
virus response
yeah i think there are democrats who are
saying that i think that
that the former vice president is in the
mindset
of normalcy of
just calm hit the marks
play to the economy play to kovid
and don't create any waves and
you know one of the the tactics here now
is that this mute button
uh there's two minutes where the
candidates will get
uninterrupted talk you know in the first
debate that didn't happen
and maybe that's not a great thing for
joe biden sometimes he doesn't get to
the bell
at least that's what we saw in the
democratic primary where he says you
know what i'm done
we'll see we'll see how that plays with
the full two minutes of an answer
so jesse dana mentioned this uh the
president's uh
trying to push the ref around here he's
been critical of kirsten welker he was
of course critical of chris wallace he
critical of steve scully uh and he
attacked the debate commission for the
mute button he doesn't like the choice
of topics
is he looking for an excuse for losing
no i think he's just being honest with
how he feels and in kristen's defense
you know my parents are far left and
look how i turned out juan
i don't know if you can always make that
case but you don't need to know who her
parents donated to to know she's a
democrat we've been watching her on
msnbc
for years she's clearly a democrat
that's fine the president
is always dealing with democrats whether
they're moderators or
people leaking about him in his own
administration so that's not the issue
he's going to go after joe biden for the
pay for play with chyna and americans
hate corruption welker will try to bail
joe out you can guarantee that but he's
going to stay focused on it
i wouldn't listen to anonymous
republicans
giving donald trump advice about how to
win
republicans lost two times in a row i
think donald trump knows how to win
and i think he should trust his
instincts there i do believe that he
should really laser focus on the economy
he can
feast on joe biden's economic record it
is atrocious
he paints biden as the pro-lockdown guy
he's got a fetish
with lockdowns for some reason that
makes no sense and it was juan supposed
to be about foreign policy
but the president's foreign policy has
been so good it's not even a topic
joe doesn't even bring it up on the
campaign trail
with the little circles of people around
him watching because it has been pretty
good
so we'll see what happens it is a
crucial debate though i mean
this race has tightened in the
battlegrounds it's neck and neck
and i think president just has to be
disciplined
focused and treat joe like he treated
hillary at that second debate in
just be really fact-based and methodical
and he'll do well
all right so greg do you think biden
will bring up trump's failure to pay
american taxes while he was paying
chinese taxes on a secret bank account
well
it it doesn't matter because the way you
positioned it is inaccurate
it's not secret but any yeah and how how
is it secret if we already know about it
anyway in terms of debate advice
i find it interesting that dana quoted a
man who settled an argument by shooting
him to death
really dana how dare you what are you
actually taking his advice
so anyway but speaking of violence
speaking of violence
joe biden once said that if you elect
him
you're going to get rid of the violence
in the street it was a subtle way of
extorting a vote from the american
people
saying that if if you if trump wins the
violence will continue
so a great question that kristen welker
could ask joe
or or uh president trump could ask joe
let's say you lose what would you say to
the angry
upset population that are going out in
the streets
uh to reduce the chances of of chaos and
unrest
and looting and arson and all the things
that we've experienced before
because if if if biden loses he told us
there's going to be more violence so
somebody's got to ask him
if he loses what is he going to say to
the population
to prevent the fires and the
and the and the violence that will 100
percent happen
because he said so